oui oui il ya beaucoup de bruit donc
beaucoup de gens qui sont un peu
d'accord avec vous martine martin on est
vraiment des cobayes selon vous pourquoi
pourquoi parce que ces vaccins
enfin ces nouveaux outils qu'on veut
bien appeler vaccins qui sont
génétiquement modifiés en fait non pas
us ce ce moment d'évaluation
bénéfice/risque suffisamment long on est
toujours dans une phase d'autorisation
de mise sur le marché conditionnelle ça
veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas réellement
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché et
que les français alors ceux qui
acceptent d'être vaccinés les français
eux mêmes le monde entier oui le
mainframe est en tout cas moi je
m'occupe des asturiens français parce
que je suis à l'assemblée nationale et
ayant en fait non pas 7
cette précision avant d'aller se faire
vacciner
j'en profite toujours pour bien préciser
que je ne suis pas anti vaccins pas
d'accord je te fais vacciner vous c'est
bien alors matinée non parce que je
défends le traitement précoce depuis un
an
d'accord elle continue à dire et je sais
que les études internationales nous
démontre tout l'intérêt des traitements
précoces
donc je ne précipite pas du tout
pourquoi il s'est un peu c'est pas un
peu dur comme oh c'est pas un peu fort
aux employés non parce que ça fait peur
ça peut faire aucune transparence il
n'ya il n'y a pas de transparence les
médecins ou les autres professionnels de
santé qui propose la vaccination et qui
vaccine les gens ne prennent pas le
temps nécessaire et suffisant pour leur
expliquer donc je crois qu'il faut être
prudent
ces vaccins sont été fabriqué
extrêmement rapidement
il n'y a pas de recul on a en plus des
pays je vais citer le danemark qui a
définitivement décidé de suspendre le
vaccin astrazeneca mais j'ai fait
plusieurs mises en demeure auprès du
ministre de la santé auprès de santé
publique france auprès de la haute
autorité de santé auprès des différentes
ars pour que la france soit un peu plus
prudente par rapport à ce vaccin à
adénovirus on sait aussi que johnson &
johnson vient d'être suspendue aux états
unis peut-être pas sur tous les
territoires j'ai pas vérifié mais en
tout cas à plusieurs endroits donc là il
me semble que ce soit bien vite à ce
qu'ils disent à ceux qui disent que
votre discours et est dangereux et
irresponsable
pour lui ça alors ceux qui ont dit ça
c'est mes collègues députés depuis que
j'ai pris du recul
depuis que j'ai été exclue d'abord en
mer mais n'a exclu de l'assemblée
nationale n'ont pas de la république au
marché saint jean ce qu'on va parler de
l'assemblée après j'ai été exclue donc
quand moment ça se passe quand on exclut
de la république en marche c'est qui qui
vous appelle à bâle ag s'est passé est
passé devant le comité exécutif
il porte bien son nom à l'époque c'était
encore gilles legendre qui présidait ce
qu'on vous dit on veut plus de vous on
m'a vu en visio il y avait 40 collègues
députés qui se frottait les mains puis
gilles legendre en introduction à lui le
communiqué de presse qui l'a qu'il avait
déjà écrit pour en fait m'exclure donc
d'accord la décision était prise avant
même que je puisse m'expliquer
simplement pourquoi j'avais été la seule
ça va je suis pas passée inaperçue
la seule députée avoir voté contre le
plan de déconfinement du doigt philippe
c'était très bizarre et on peut on peut
se dire mais elle est quand même un peu
curieuse parce qu'elle n'est pas
forcément pour le confinement est elle
votre contrôle des confinement oui parce
qu'à l'époque tout ouvrir et tous des
consignes et là encore sans proposer de
stratégies thérapeutiques me paraissait
être un total non sens alors